en este vídeo continuaremos hablando
sobre el análisis sea y el concepto de
impedancia como la proporción de voltaje
a corriente en una situación de
corriente alterna recordemos las
suposiciones que hemos hecho en el
análisis de corriente alterna todas
nuestras señales tienen forma de
senoidal es típicamente elegimos el
coseno coseno de omega t más un
desplazamiento de fase iii también
usaremos la ecuación de oyler que dice
que podemos descomponer un coseno en dos
exponenciales complejas una de las
exponenciales complejas es el ala más j
por omega temas fi
más o menos jota por omega t más fin y
cuando usamos los términos de oilers nos
encanta ponerlos en ecuaciones
diferenciales así que arrastremos cada
uno de estos términos uno a la vez a
través de nuestros circuitos típicamente
nos vamos a enfocar en el término con el
signo positivo para el término con el
signo negativo las matemáticas serán las
mismas a excepción de dicho signo
negativo cuando definimos el término de
impedancia supusimos que de hoy tienen
esta forma de exponencial compleja por
lo que cuando éstos pasan por nuestros
componentes llegamos a la idea de
impedancia como repaso recordemos que
para nuestra resistencia su impedancia
es igual a r esta es la proporción de b
hay en una resistencia para un inductor
decimos que su impedancia es igual a j
omega l
y finalmente para un capacitor de valor
se la impedancia será igual a 1 / j o
mega c estas son las inferencias de
nuestros tres componentes pasivos
favoritos sus unidades son oms para
todas las impedancia las de las
resistencias los inductores y los
capacitores quizás pueda parecernos
extraño por tener este término de la
frecuencia aquí pero no se preocupen así
quedan las unidades veamos esto
cualitativamente el valor de estas
impedancia sse en específico veamos qué
pasa cuando tenemos un rango de valores
para el término de omega que pasa cuando
tenemos una frecuencia de 0 cuando
tenemos una frecuencia baja cuando
tenemos una frecuencia alta y cuando
tenemos una frecuencia infinita vamos a
hacerlo veamos los términos de
impedancia con diferentes frecuencias y
veremos la frecuencia en radiales
hagamos la tabla y ahora pondremos
nuestros componentes primero veamos
nuestra resistencia y pongamos los
valores que corresponden a z
que sabemos es igual a r para cualquier
frecuencia
sabemos que r siempre es igual a r así
que esto es muy sencillo para la
frecuencia zero rsr para frecuencias
bajas eres r para las frecuencias altas
rsr y para frecuencias infinitas r sigue
siendo r no hay dependencia con la
frecuencia en r ahora veamos al inductor
la impedancia de un inductor es j omega
l y permítanme hacer algo muy específico
puede quitar esta j
vamos a ver básicamente la magnitud de
la impedancia será omega l ahora tenemos
la tabla para un mega l
'cuando omega es 0 la magnitud de la
impedancia será 0 para un inductor
cuando la frecuencia es baja la
impedancia será relativamente baja y
conforme aumenta la frecuencia entonces
omega l aumentará también por lo que se
vuelve alta y si dejamos que la
frecuencia llegue a infinito
llegar a infinito también por lo que la
impedancia será infinita vemos que para
un inductor desde frecuencias bajas
hasta frecuencias altas la impedancia
del inductor va desde cero hasta
infinito y pongamos nuestro último
componente el capacitor la impedancia de
un capacitor es igual a 1 / j o megas y
la magnitud de la impedancia es uno
entre omega se escribamos los valores
cuanto vale 1 / omega c cuando omega es
0 bueno pues es infinito y qué pasa
cuando omega es un número pequeño pues
si omega es pequeña aquí tendremos un
número más grande por lo que aquí
tendremos un valor alto
y si la frecuencia es muy alta entonces
mientras más alta sea o mega más pequeña
será la magnitud vez etc etc es anti
simétrica con respecto al inductor
finalmente si la frecuencia es infinita
1 / infinito por c será igual a 0 con
esta tabla podemos introducir algunos
términos informales que usamos en
ingeniería eléctrica para describir el
comportamiento de hélice en diferentes
frecuencias como dijimos antes r es el
mismo sin importar la frecuencia la
impedancia es constante en un inductor
la impedancia cambia con la frecuencia
cuando la frecuencia es cero o cuando la
frecuencia es baja la impedancia es muy
baja lo que nos lleva a la expresión que
decimos de que un inductor se comporta
como un cortocircuito en frecuencias
bajas cuando tenemos frecuencias altas
la impedancia aumenta y eventualmente
llega a infinito
esta es la impedancia de un circuito
abierto por lo que decimos que l se
comporta como un circuito abierto en
frecuencias altas
y como cortocircuito en frecuencias
bajas vemos la misma terminología
informal para nuestro capacitor el
capacitor cuando la frecuencia es cero
tiene una impedancia infinita tiene una
impedancia infinita por lo que luce como
un circuito abierto en frecuencias bajas
y cómo se comporta en frecuencias altas
la impedancia se vuelve baja cuando las
frecuencias son altas y cuando la
frecuencia es infinita la impedancia es
cero y esa es la impedancia de un
cortocircuito perfecto así que decimos
que un capacitor se comporta como un
cortocircuito en frecuencias altas la
razón por la que comento esto es porque
con mucha frecuencia los ingenieros
experimentados usan esta terminología
informal y esto puede confundir a los
ingenieros novatos por lo que quiero
mostrarles de dónde vienen estos
términos y que significan esta no es una
idea simple ya vieron cuántas
suposiciones hicimos y el trabajo
necesario para llegar a esta idea y
poder entender esas expresiones comunes
sobre cómo funcionan los componentes
espero que esto les ayude a comprender
qué significan y de dónde vienen